bonjour tu restes en 7 à vous vous êtes
un soutien d'alain juppé et on sait que
les jeunes sont une cible pour lui et on
pour les convaincre on l'a vu faire un
bing pont d'ain 18ème arrondissement
c'est des jeux d'alcool est ce que pour
convaincre des jeunes ça passe par là je
pense que quand on voit le succès de
bernie sanders qui est très à la mode en
ce moment avec ses 74 ans et qui je
crois a raflé 80
presque 90 % du suffrage des jeunes
démocrates aux états unis face à hillary
clinton
c'est pas une question de profil du
candidat
c'est aussi une question de proposition
et de projets est la nôtre bernie
sanders et alain juppé je le fais parce
que la première chose qu'on me dit après
avoir expliqué que je défends la
candidature d'alain juppé c'est quand
même
et derrière la question de la séduction
des jeunes il ya ça malgré tout qui
affleure en filigrane vous soutenez un
candidat qui a déjà un certain âge et
moi je pense très honnêtement que la
politique c'est pas les émissions de
télé réalité c'est pas le fait d'aller
singer les choses mais ça peut être
malgré tout d'avoir une forme de
spontanéité dans les rencontres qu'on a
avec les uns et les autres il faut pas
être dans une maîtrise ont fini par être
comme un robot mais dans le même temps
il faut pas se travestir et il ya une
ligne entre les deux il faut être
capable de suivre celle de l'odéon neda
anti système
j'irai pas jusque là je pense que
honnêtement il a aujourd'hui une
obsession c'est celle d'être utile à son
pays en se disant qu' il peut sans doute
être le plus à même de rassembler après
un quinquennat
entre 2007 et 2012 qui a déçu une partie
des électeurs de droite et un candidat
qui n'est pas terminé mais qui semble
devoir décevoir une partie des électeurs
de gauche dans votre région il y a un
rendez-vous qui est apprécié par
certains jeunes c'est le hellfest
festival ça fait polémique avec bruno
retailleau
est ce qu'on peut y croiser alain juppé
il ira séduire quelques jeunes alors
qu'est ce que c'est que le hellfest
festival c'est un festival de hard rock
de rock métal alors à ma connaissance ce
festival qui accueille plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes
n'accueille pas que des jeunes si vous
voulez entre 18 et 25 ans je crois au
contraire qu'il ya pas mal de cadres à
qui sont assez fan de ce type de musique
je connais pas suffisamment bien les
goûts musicaux d'alain juppé pour
pouvoir vous répondre si vous avez une
chance de le croiser il ya un livre dont
on parle beaucoup c'est celui de nicolas
sarkozy qui apparemment s'est vendu à
plus de cent mille exemplaires c'est ce
qui est le chiffre qui est avancé il a
dit qu'il allait faire des dédicaces
dans les supermarchés notamment entre le
rayon charcuterie les poissonneries
c'est une place inattendue pour annoncer
un chef de l'état que les hommes
politiques et le souci d'aller
rencontrer les français là où ils sont
c'est pas quelque chose qui me choque et
ils se moquent d'alain juppé qui lui
apparemment préféreraient les grandes
écoles
moi vous savez ce genre de petites
phrases
il va falloir s'y habituer dans les
semaines qui viennent jusqu'à la
primaire je pense franchement que les
français attendent autre chose quand on
regarde la situation dans laquelle on
est économiquement socialement
sécuritairement la crise des migrants
franchement la somme des défis auxquels
on est confrontés font que si on reste
scotché sur l'espèce de deux niveaux qui
est celui de la cour de récré il faudra
pas s'étonner que la colère des
électeurs de plus en plus elles prennent
la forme ou de l'abstention ou de vote
en faveur des extrêmes et là je vais
vous dire il faudra pas chercher
d'autres excuses peu plus d'une minute
est ce que alain juppé l'a déjà gagnée
on l'a vu qu'il a déjà distribué
certains postes à ses proches notamment
à virginie calmels ce qui est déjà
assuré d'être maire de bordeaux s'il
gagne vous avez déjà un poste qui
il est prévu non merci de me poser cette
question
d'abord il n'y a rien de fait et c'est
l'état d'esprit de personnes
ces primaires elles sont ouvertes
personne ne sait combien de gens vont se
déplacer pour voter et j'appelle moi
toutes celles et tous ceux qui veulent
pouvoir peser sur la prochaine élection
présidentielle à se déplacer pour ces
primaires s'autoproclamer vainqueur
c'est le meilleur moyen de ne pas gagner
une élection il ya des élections
primaires il y aura ensuite une élection
présidentielle le chemin est très long
et à aucun moment il faut effectivement
donné sentiment que les choses sont
faites en tout cas à titre personnel je
suis pas du tout dans une
je suis pas dans autre chose que dans le
fait de m'impliquer dans une élection
qui compte pour mon pays je n'ai pas
d'ambition personnelle pour na qui
arrive je les dis et redis localement le
chemin est long on retiendra sa en tout
cas merci vous côté